tá brincando no ano a conta o ator diz
pessoal daqui quem falou dark e sejam
muito bem vindos já nice 1 viol eo
mostrados aqui alto oeste 2 the row eu
ir para o desfile vai ser todo sem
cortes bom o jogo seguiu ontem sua
outras 2 denunciou ontem aqui na psn eu
já não sei que você tem que descobrir o
plano está em frente e bom hoje eu vou
tentar fazer quando é que os vídeos como
eu fazia lá atrás sabem que eu dar um
freio antigo em cantar frank oitava os
filhos hoje vai ser simples eu sei que
muita gente gosta e com o clash 2 e
assim dando assim mais cumprido eu vou
tentar não contar também porque vocês
gostam rio também que a experiência
estou mas sim e eu não pude ficar fora
da edição e bora lá pessoal já teme que
o jogo e nós lá está uma ideia logo as
lans igual tanto da classe 2 de abril a
dupla toca aí eu subo e klindermann sou
um camelô que está a trabalhar com a
minha mulher
lino e nós dois temos que investigar e
não são jornalistas e temos de um ciclo
e no cubo story sabe como inglês e mesmo
assim só tem folhas de ouro fogo entrou
em um novo ciclo das estatuetas possível
mandar pra mim que obama não usou lei do
[ __ ] não sair estou mesmo tempo
português vitor em português
toda essa história vamos lá vou eu tô
aqui pra trabalhar só porque já estou
ansioso por estar há muito tempo
é isso nós vamos investigar
o que o filme está aqui dentro só que
tanto no trailer né
isso já traz uma mulher né ai ai como
funciona pessoal
ok na falésia
temos que chegar a coisas e já coloquei
o meu ato olha só tá todo mundo e chega
acaba me acalma está muito real muito
real lula logo o doi cima e pra baixo
só vamos descobrir esta falência
uma coisa não é só a montanha que já tem
uma casa e ouvi nos treinos quem é que
aqui nesta casa tem um substituto para
ele isso é isso que eu sei que aqui
dentro já tem um susto
van marwijk disse luís assopra da globo
a dar trancada
tenho nem deu pra se enfrentaram a
estátua chato não há nada aqui e vamos
embora entanto sua obra handebol já tem
uma luz mostra o desenho é feito todo em
frente só não consigo ver nada está
muito escuro eu devia ter aumentado
brasil nessas folhas o rio venha falar
que alguém falou aqui lá atrás de sua
estrela
um homem é um assassino era chato né
gostei que uma casa que que eu acho que
esta casa tem um susto quando seis gols
window ou de tamanho e doutras uma bota
aí estão vindo e isso tem uma janela a
eu prefiro uma coruja não tiveram um
gosto kyi win do prestígio tutorial
quase nula e já felipe soares como os
que eu ganhei espaço estava assim mas é
isso uma casa humilde ao mais alto nível
o problema é que o brasil que tem por
aqui ao lado né
só agora com um baixo saltar eu sei
o treino ainda bolinha é isso é isso aí
vamos lá pessoal e vamos em frente
e já agora eu cortei o cabelo estou aqui
só fique lá nunca ninguém aqui em cima
eu não sei se eu gosto é o que importa
vamos agora entrar no cemitério oi já
tem alguém não gosta que aqui também um
pouco comigo
hosken eu falo assim
é isso é uma armadilha que não é e não
conseguiu empurrar um está tudo escuro
casa já está tudo escuro nunca e não fez
nem aí não fez nada no tubo e não sei
contou já com o estatuto e agora ganhou
fãs não vejo o presidente da câmara é
claro que é muito burro muito burro da
pesquisa câmara clara estava tudo isso
lá exatamente lá eu acho que essa parte
também no trailer né
acho que se inscrever entre elas terão
alguma coisa né corpo muito que
conquistar a atenção atrás de mim eu
tenho curso que ela é uma vilã em um
festa para já não vi eu acho do luke
harding diz o que se passa muito rápido
e talca exatamente já saiu já se já vai
só vai só mas só em frente e esquecer o
resto
em 2000 e não andando na frente
ela está muito confuso como usar o bando
é muito confuso
pessoalmente não só estou a gravar em
1920 pp que alguém traz minha lei e por
onde quer que se olhe lá em cima ninguém
daria o título aqui em cima de uma
válvula
- foi uma coisa pra apanhar pelo o que
eu acho que não abre
adoro a porta ou outra porta exatamente
esta pode funcionar uma escola católica
o que é isso mesmo
isso abriu aqui abril
só que eu vou dar um piloto mais tarde
porque ainda é tranquila em agora da
folha as folhas
agora sou
eu gosto de música da bosta
isto traz tony stark encheram ontem uma
mensagem secreta lei
não sei por que vocês viram na mão uma
merda aqui hoje para
assim fosse sua fase não dá nada não não
ligou o nome morreu na hora
no comando fabril um cacifo pista que já
tem um choque em minha senha quebras
estava no ar
não há nada aqui a vacinar se apartava
eita players ou x 1 fique o eixo estou e
não achando que tem negro tem calma
calma mulher assim
a escola católica no canadá primeira
ópera se nao sou eu uma pessoa focada e
sua equipe e eu nem liguei a tv e foi
essa tv você tem uma opção e ou o opel
assim comigo eu tenho certeza que quando
eu saía da porta a porta vai fechar
não não é deus
weather só vai pra casa
já pensou se a pessoa já está tudo bem é
e é incrível
entretanto junto olha só há um caminho
só ato o caminho francês funeral cué
sempre caminhou jack daley eo a opzz uau
apanharam [ __ ] não conseguiu fugir
não é igual a surgir lá
eu não contou nem quanto foi chocar
roger ex esposa de esforço nem surge da
escola mais rápido com o íleo tô legal
que hoje leva o número de fugas trio faz
baixo eo [ __ ] ilegais entrarem com
ternos e agora o que eu faço tem que
tentar o gol né
sozinho
ai apanharam um vírus anai
ai eu cozinho gostoso tá acelerar agora
pessoal e agora pronto está o flash é
assim funciona meu irmão que o dem jogos
e perseguições
eu odeio cinco seleções em jogos em
jogos karak agora confessa ter impulso
não a posso eu vou apanhar culpa que eu
faça o que eu faço não saiu sobre o gol
de gervinho e facilita plantada de mim
vai entrar e vai pegar fogo
são cortados o corpo do corretor onda
quando isso tudo a ver e agora nenhum eu
vou tentar ser menos
gilberto olhar de um opel vir aqui o
treinador já eu sou perto onde é que eu
tenho que ver onde é que ontem que não
faz ideia é só sair só sei que eu tenho
que fazer
o alto verão 2011 irão não anda e foi
onde se eu tentar perceber porque não
contêm kimmel
será que há algo aqui numa destas ervas
em suas mortes e que encaram aproveitar
pra mim eu estou virando uma estranha
ele é irmão dos muito estranha é isso é
porque suas no fogo
não choro encontrar só saltar isso não é
othon funciona [ __ ]
estou funciona
eu acho que é porque tem que continuar a
obra
hoje vou socorrer [ __ ] se eu vou correr
eu vou só correr correr de um bioma o
meu cu o meu cozinha está centrada no
metrô
[ __ ] superbid através do socó socó
é muita perseguição muita perseguição
anunciou ontem que meu outro corre atrás
vai vai vai entrar aqui
oi
ae
elton quase morreu do coração que eu
possa morrer não morrer sarto aguenta já
atua depois um homem forte é um senhor
bem capaz de aguentar com estes senhores
vai lá só corta tudo fluía
a exemplo vai ter muitos gols o socorro
socorro socorro socorro
ai ai eu entreguei a ele não só não
tinha um senhor perigo
tome uma parceria que autuações
fui estudar só esta última parte foi sem
palavras ela ela explicou machado
no meu órgão piano até sangrar que o
sangue só é isso vamos ficar porque
conheci ao 32 espero que vocês tenham
gostado deste lírio atenção este é o
vídeo sem cortes importantes de uma ilha
na sua opinião se acham que que isto
fique bem e vocês querem ver uma série
sem dar sugestões sem cortes mas querem
ver com corte com a edição de uma
interface jardim o que vocês querem
e aí pessoal sá vai deixando a sua
opinião sobre o s2 sequer em seis
se gostaram da minha opinião é que sim
eu gostei adorei isso foi brutal e é
isso que eu estou aqui favorito fique
bem e até a próxima